[Music]
in a place called
dover foxcroft maine
oh i love it there change it change the
name i love that change
why pic pick jim town too many syllables
trot that's the name foxcroft fox kiss
off
always those people foxcroft you never
heard of it those places have nothing to
dfc offer like that's cool that makes
one of people visit
you haven't seen the mountains no let me
explain
besides just the name it sounds like
they're specialized in
llama milk too llama milk llama milk and
corn oh yeah
you should definitely try their almond
milk creamy rich lava milk and corn
if pigs if they had pig's milk they just
came out with it today oh pigs milk like
pork milk
yes would you drink it oh i never even
thought about like that i'll try
whatever
oh yeah i'll try it once but i don't
know how clean
yeah it's probably really bad i'm down
here because pigs spank
yeah they stink they do they smell bad
we literally eat their meat yeah that's
why
yeah but then but the hormones boil it
yeah the hormones and
the hormones inside the milk is another
thing they want the cow's milk
i'm down to try how come we don't milk
those [ __ ] i heard that the
lady pigs have
uh 30 minute orgasms 30 minutes wow
you watch pig porn the how do you know
i read it on a blog never what log
all right anyway so in dover dover
foxcroft maine
uh there is a house they actually have
the actress here so if you ever want to
visit this house it's it's on this
particular
uh acre of property there are two homes
built the original house
is and then a couple decades later a new
house is built
uh and they're on the same lot now when
this house was built
they also you know divided the the acre
and then divided there was like an
actual border
uh to property lines to the pro property
line
it's still all one owner though uh no
it's actually
owned by the the new people that built
the new house there now
yeah i guess they sold that portion of
the land to them yeah but
um it's on the piece of land that the
original family owned
and so did that properly divide the
proper property line
at the time and now you have two quakers
fighting over it basically
yes so long story short
picture like dwight schrute's family
hold on i'm so done
everyone's jumping in restate what
happened okay there's one
large piece of property one property
then they split it into
two now there's two homes yes on each
side
yes but it seems like no they were doing
it without
the homes property i don't think so yeah
it seemed where'd it go they weren't
very clear with the property line before
and so that has led to
a lot of uh bickering between the two
families that live on these properties
this is on my
land okay and originally
they got along fine but when the father
of the new portion of the house
died and left it in his wife's name and
his sons took over
that's when chaos ensued and as a final
fix of the whole situation
they decided i'm still new to this
they put up bobbed wire
do this i can't see wait what they chop
a house in half
they chop the garage in half whose house
this a garage
this is chopped directly in half is this
the second property
this is the second property and the
photo's being taken from the original
property
whoa the original owners cut into the
second
the original owners are like [ __ ] you
guys i know how to
handle this situation here's the final
my final matter of a few
feet that they're doing matter of fact
every time i hear these stories i'm
always like you're this
petty what happened okay what happened
so what happened it looks like a nice
house too what led to this
is that the father of this house passed
away and he was kind of like the
peacekeeper between the two families
all right when he passed away the wife
just stopped living there she started
going
elsewhere so basically the only people
that were living here
were the suns and the friends of the sun
they kept parting parties and like just
strangers kept coming in they didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going on
there was noise and all this stuff so
they're like complaining like hey
can you keep it down over there like we
also live on this property
and there was god it's kind of like with
our neighbor the old place
the old place yeah yeah and at the time
there was no fence this fence is also
brand new and in fact i don't think they
finished building the fence yet they're
still
kind of constructing it who built this
fence this fence is built by
these owners yeah okay and so what what
sparked
this uh ex extreme cutting of the garage
though
was they this family over here on this
side
the original family they were doing some
construction and they needed to get
a tractor into their property
i guess the only way they could was to
go through between these two properties
and kind of like go in so they moved
some stuff
onto this border this imaginary border
and this family got pissed because it's
their stuff that got moved
uh no it's it's their stuff that's moved
on to their property yeah and so
this family decided to drive a steak
into the ground whatever that even means
so i'm like what does that even look
like a steak into there a stick into the
ground
you know like a piece of meat i don't
know no a steak
like a s-t-a-k-e oh like yeah like it's
a rod
yeah yeah yeah like i this is my this is
my area
don't [ __ ] put your [ __ ] here and
then
this family was like well [ __ ] you for
doing that
and we're gonna just cut your [ __ ]
[ __ ] in half
and uh we're gonna call a land surveyor
and see where exactly the border is
okay wow they should call the land
surveyor before cutting
oh no they i know that they did do that
and they figured it out so it's like
this is all my property yeah so they're
like your garage is actually on our side
of the land so
[ __ ] your [ __ ] this half of the garage
because it's on my piece of land
and this is the tool okay here's some
more images oh
it's clean that's [ __ ] fun
like a lego piece came out no that's
that's the original house on that side
of the on the other
what an eyesore yeah but that's some
petty [ __ ] i love it
yeah that's like i thank god for people
like this to exist so you could laugh at
them
yeah and then they use this that really
that's a good brand deal dude
i was like what the [ __ ] wi-fi too
you were able to take a whole damn
garage in half with just that yeah i
think
that's really good it's so precise
sawzall sawzell
saw yeah you got problems with your
neighbors get a sawzall
act now nobody went out to stop them or
call the cops so they were gone no no
because that's the other family
they were in and out all the time like
there was no one actually living there
consecutively like for days so like
there was just like on that day that
they weren't there they just saw the
girls
so that's even extra petty because
the original owners were upset that that
the new owners
are making a whole bunch of mess or like
loud loud noise
yeah but they're not even there all the
time and that led them to do this
like yeah that's so petty hey petty and
then now they're erecting
a fence so that they could once and for
all just be done with that side of
it's it's funny because like when you
showed the picture of their house
i was like i was expecting from where
the picture of the fence was taken
like uh go back to the this is like
literally next yeah like right there but
then they showed it was far like
how much noise were they making yeah
it's like way over here they're probably
like i don't want to hear a peep from
you guys
this one that one yeah that's the
original they should now go into their
garage
and play music but since there's no wall
it's like loud
now they should push it right to the
edge like the speaker's like right at
the edge maybe even a little bit over
that's [ __ ] pissed well isn't that
like destroying someone's property
though
even though if it's on your line can you
get in trouble no i don't think so i
guess not
because legally it's their problem yeah
i think there's a way to get them in
trouble for sure but
well in california you probably get in
trouble but in another who gets in
trouble in california
well in california like if someone comes
and like freaking takes my butthole and
i punch them in the face i'm in trouble
still how do they take your butt
i don't know but they come on my
property they take my butthole and i
punch them in the face i'm still in
trouble
true so i guess in california if
if i don't know like they built on my
property
and i cut their chunk off i feel like
i'm in trouble
but another state is different is that
like a blue state versus red state kind
of thing usually i don't know
boost dates tend to favor the landowner
i think
yeah they favor the tenant they favor
the favor the tenant but then in this
case
it's two land owners so it's a former
it's just one's the original land owner
and sold it i feel like it should have
been
where i don't know how any of the law
works but
it should you should have got a court
order to like move it you have like 30
days and if you don't
i'm taking action i could do whatever
they probably found out that they are in
within their legal rights to do this and
they're like oh now we're
really going to [ __ ] them the ass cause
they're just being asked i mean we don't
know the full article they probably
could have done that where they got
someone and be like yo
like legally you have to move what we're
going to do this and they're like no
we're calling you
that's true yeah in the article they did
say at one point they've tried
buying the property back but they
weren't selling to them
so they're just kind of like are you
[ __ ] up for splitting your property
yeah that's a nightmare like imagine you
didn't have neighbors and you're just
like
yeah you know what i think it's time to
sell some land and you get
nightmare neighbors and you can't do
anything
oh i think i would just hire organized
crime to come and
terrorize them oh [ __ ] i was going to
throw rats oh i like rats go into your
property yeah but they're going to come
back
i'm going to get a bunch of rats the
whole neighborhood's going to have more
snakes
all right i don't think this is going to
be snakes to eat them thanks guys
there's too many snakes
oh wait now we got to get mongoose yeah
oh yeah now there's a mongoose problem
it's like oh [ __ ] what are we going to
do cats
i don't know who eats not mongoose all
right thanks guys you guys maybe tigers
we'll get tigers all right tigers in
maine yeah yeah yeah
i'll put up like fake machine guns
machines you gotta
go like this all day that's probably
illegal oh my god they're fake
no that's probably illegal they're nerf
guns okay like how you try to check
their fate damn what would you do
i mean i always think about that too
because like this is like
neighbors yeah the visual of this
is amazing as long as it doesn't
escalate to murder like
it looks like it's getting like i know
once you damage someone's property
you're asking for a forget to murder man
yeah she's like what's funny but it's
it's it's on the it's on the line if you
were this family on on this side right
the the problem family and you come home
to see that you saw this what is what is
your next move my next step would be to
light a bag of
uh dog [ __ ] yeah oh yeah you can move
slow
yeah because they went too far you take
your time oh but you're gonna get back
with the [ __ ]
stilts dude i'm [ __ ] chainsawing all
those stilts
i'd move the house an inch back oh my
god you're just
every year an inch back
okay jim
put all their [ __ ] in jello yeah
damn i know like um it kind of reminded
me a little bit of
of our neighbor situations obviously not
as dramatic as this but
when in the previous home that we lived
in it was a town home
so it's like uh you know a whole
building and a lot of like condos pretty
much
like they're all sharing walls and so we
lived
like the second to the last on on our
building
and so the neighbor to the left well i
mean
yes left they were really nice really
sweet never had issues
the ones on the right they ended up uh
so it was this woman she she owned that
property
she ended up getting cancer so she
passed and so her daughter
inherited that that property and then so
the daughter moved in with her boyfriend
and they would like the boyfriend was
super loud they would get into crazy
arguments
and like at two in the morning he'd be
kicking it in the front of the property
like a little like patio area and so our
bedroom window is above
like diagonally that way so you hear
everything you can hear
everything sex arguments
uh drunken knives drunken knife music
it's just like
everything we know everything about
their lives how annoying
so then the woman who got cancer um
that's the cousin of our landlord so
then we talked to our landlord and we're
like hey you know your family is really
loud like can we please just somehow
end it we need our sleep luckily it was
it was okay like i said it wasn't this
dramatic
um but yeah it just sucks when you have
really loud shitty neighbors that are
just inconsiderate of
people that they're living around
because we literally shared a wall like
we consider it but i guess not
[Music]
you